Speaker 1: So we are getting absolutely no
respite whatsoever from the profligate barrage
of fake scandals relating to Joe Biden that
are emanating from right wing media.
And one thing I've learned in covering politics
is that there are always scandals for every
president.
Sometimes they're real, sometimes they're
completely fake and made up for political
purposes.
No president is perfect, but Joe Biden's first
100 days are actually looking pretty good.
First and foremost, developing a top global
vaccination campaign after being handed trash
by the Trump administration such that the
US has now vaccinated 42 percent of the population
is likely one month from dramatic reductions
in cases and deaths, probably more like three
weeks, even passing covid stimulus and getting
money to people within a couple of months
of getting in with no Republican support,
literally zero Republican votes for that bill,
reestablishing some global relationships with
countries that were driven away by the incompetence
of the Trump administration.
For those who care about the stock market,
as many claims to under Donald Trump, record
stock market highs under Joe Biden.
And it's been three months.
OK, so right wing media is coming up with
fake scandals.
I won't list all of the ones we've looked
at so far.
You know, everything from the the relationship
between Joe and Joe Biden is fake to all these
different fake scandals.
There's just too many.
I'm just going to focus on the ones from this
weekend alone.
We already talked about the fake scandal that
Joe Biden would ban meat and beer.
So that's one.
I won't go over it again since we did that
earlier in the show here yesterday morning
is Fox News anchor and long time Trump brownnoser
Maria Bartiromo announcing that during the
recent world leader Climate Zoome meeting,
Biden didn't have a U.S. flag behind him.
That's the scandal.
Take a look at this,
Speaker 3: by the way, in that shot.
I think it's really also interesting to point
out that President Biden is the only leader
without a flag behind him.
Everybody has their flag.
We don't have the American flag behind Joe
Biden, interestingly.
Speaker 1: Whoa.
That is really.
Can Biden even recover from that?
I mean, that's really, really serious.
Fox News is reporting about the absence of
a flag during a virtual meeting as a scandal.
They wouldn't report on Trump's historic global
failure on covid while it was going on.
But the absence of a flag during this meeting
is a scandal for FOX News.
Here's another big scandal.
Former Republican Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich appeared on Judge Jeanine Pirro Weekend
Show to tell us there are people that are
appalled, Jeanine.
Appalled.
That the Biden administration is, quote, flying
the gay flag at American embassies around
the world.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: Every idiotic thing that the Obama
administration has done in the first hundred
days, you begin to realize whether it's threatening
everybody who believes in the Second Amendment
or it's attacking everybody who believes in
right to life or and is attacking people of
traditional values who are appalled that this
administration would fly the gay flag at American
embassies all over the world.
I mean, you just go down item by item and
it's almost like they have a checklist.
Speaker 1: Biden is disrespecting people with
traditional values, which is one of the most
important coded phrases I can think of.
He's offending people with traditional values
because the gay flag, as he calls it, is flying
at embassies in other countries.
People with traditional values are going around
paying attention to the flags being flown
at American embassies in other countries.
That alone would be a shock.
And if that's really what they're concerned
about, they must really not have much going
on in their lives.
But that's another fake Fox News scandal concocted
this weekend.
The next scandal is less about Biden specifically,
but it's Democrats bigger picture.
Republican Congressman Mike Turner was also
on Maria Bartiromo show yesterday, and he
floated a completely unhinged conspiracy theory
that Democrats want to block the U.S. from
making a nuclear first strike in order to
prevent generals from defending us against
against adversaries so that if an adversary
attacks the U.S., we would just get destroyed
as a country.
Take a listen to what Mike Turner said to
Maria Bartiromo.
Speaker 3: And then you've got Democrats led
by Elizabeth Warren, reintroducing a bill
to block the U.S. from using nuclear weapons.
First, what's the logic?
Speaker 2: There really isn't any.
That's for our security.
The Bush administration, is it proposing 16
percent increases everywhere else.
But in defense, Elizabeth Warren obviously
wants to tie the hands of our generals so
that they cannot defend against our adversaries.
We need to make certain that America stands
strong, that we build a strong military, that
we rise to the occasion against the modernization
of China and Russia.
And with that, we'll be able to keep our allies
in the United States safe.
Speaker 1: Understand that what Mike Turner
is alleging is that there are Democrats in
the Senate that are treasonous and they would
allow the U.S. to just be destroyed.
He's saying Democrats, including Elizabeth
Warren, if the U.S. were attacked, they would
say, do nothing here, take me, take all of
us, kill us, take over the country.
And that's crazy.
But also, if it were true, you would imagine
that there would be way more people saying,
oh, these these are these are traitors and
there are people saying it.
But there would be much more of that.
And Mike Turner is completely unhinged in
his claim.
And by the way, I thought that we didn't have
anything to defend ourselves with.
Remember, Donald Trump used to tell the stories
about when I took office, the generals came
to me and they said, sir, we have no bullets,
we have nothing.
So now we have things thanks to Trump.
But Elizabeth Warren, if you can imagine that,
doesn't want anybody to be allowed to use
the things and the country should just be
allowed to be destroyed.
And then here are just a few little tidbits
about the steak and beer thing.
Again, earlier in the show, we spoke about
the fake story that Biden wants to ban steak
and beer, like eliminate them from people's
diets by force.
Listen to Judge Jeanine talk about that.
Speaker 3: Finally tonight, do you
Speaker 1: like red meat?
And then this continued,
Speaker 2: so the cows must go.
Speaker 1: And she went with this for some
more time.
Here's a little bit more.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I like burgers and I like
my gas powered car, and I'm sick of China
having the upper hand over us.
Speaker 1: OK, so that that one has actually
infected more serious discussions about infrastructure
and Biden's climate and energy plan.
So we dealt with it separately earlier in
the show.
And you can go back to that segment if you
want to see more about that.
But in the meantime, if these are the scandals,
maybe Joe Biden is actually doing OK because
these scandals are completely fake.
And I think we can say, thankfully, in the
sense that it's good when polling reflects
what's going on in the real world.
Joe Biden's approval rating is is quite healthy.
Joe Biden's approval uncovered vaccination
is doing very well.
His approval on covid relief is doing well.
I think that these are all good signs for
Joe Biden